no to make America great do from
strength or get crush every time I don't
know what's going on with her such a
nasty rust fine Hillary Clinton's gonna
be a horrible president every time I
think about Trump I get allergic hey
when your star they left to do it you
can do anything
well guy you gotta see this guy oh I
don't know what I said
oh I don't remember I would imagine you
can only get worse they're bringing
crime they're rapists but we have some
bad umbrage here and we're gonna get
them out and some I assume are good
people and we're gonna build a world
who's going to pay for the wall and I
think you can see I'm having a good time
I really am Verrocchio Donald's
disgusting me both inside and out
you've called women you don't like fat
pigs dogs take a look at her she's a
slob slobs and disgusting animals your
Twitter account totally Rosie O'Donnell
like you wouldn't have your job if you
weren't beautiful get worried about my
tone look at my african-american over
here look at him hello J Trump is
calling for a total and complete
shutdown of Muslims entering the United
States USA USA Wow
don't worry about that baby I love
babies so I like it
what a baby actually I was only kidding
you can get the baby out here oh not all
our choices but tonight I like it a lot
better if I get there I'm a super seat
bocahantas that's just Elizabeth Lauren
I call her goofy and Isis now is
building a hotel in Iraq they're
competing with me you believe it France
if you had 25 people in there that had
guns okay would have been a totally
different story folks if you baka were
my daughter perhaps I'd be dating her
yeah
yes immigrants on the whole create earth
come on try getting it out try getting
it I'll get it out I mean I don't know
if you're gonna put this on television
but you don't even know what you're
talking about
I never attacked him on his look and
believe me there's plenty of subject
matter right there that I can tell you
Jake okay never see did you ever see a
sign that says Jeb Bush or Bush now
there's a reason he doesn't use this
listening this is not gonna work too
well
we had a lot of problems with that last
minute they said to Marco Rubio are you
having fun he's sweating like a pig I
never saw a guy sweat like this you
gotta get out there November 8th I don't
care how sick you are vote for Donald J
Trump very simple very simple
you